hi everyone and welcome so my name is
Francesco and I'm a business analyst in
the Google Play team and today we will
talk together with Toby about
influencers but let me start by
introducing one of them to you so his
name is yarn is a YouTube gaming
influencers and he has a channel called
orange juice gaming with more than 1
million subscribers so these people
really trust his gaming reviews and we
are here today together with Toby to
told to tell you more about the value
that we think yarn as well as other
YouTube influencers like him can bring
to your business so today we'll go
through three main areas the first one
is about the influencer opportunity and
challenges then I will walk you through
a methodology that we built internally
in Google to measure the full value of
influencer marketing and then Toby will
finish by telling you some best
practices on how to build a successful
influencer strategy going forward so we
all know this YouTube is a big thing and
it is a big thing on the user side so
what research says is that 90% of gamers
turn to YouTube at least once a week to
discover gaming content this gaming
content could be about advancement tips
maybe users of stuck into a level and
want to know how to get through it could
be to watch their favorite creator
playing games or to discover new games
so definitely YouTube is a big thing on
the user side but what about on the
developer side well I'm sure that you
know from your business that it is a big
thing on a developer side as well so
game developers already today spend more
than 250 million a year on influencer
content and this number is forecasted to
grow a lot in the next few years but
that's what research says I'm actually
curious to know within this room how
many of you spend on influencer content
in the past couple of years
please hands up pretty much everyone and
how many of you are hundreds
confident that the methodology that he
used to evaluate the full impact of
these campaigns is fully accurate one
person okay we should talk afterwards I
actually agree with you it's it's really
really tough to measure the full impact
of influencer content and there is this
big industry attribution challenge that
I'm sure everyone in this room faces so
the way works today
is that developers would collaborate
together with creators then these
YouTube creators or influencers will
produce a video upload the video into
their channel and then include one of
these trackable links in the description
underneath the video and then obviously
developers would hope that all the users
who watch the video and are interested
to download the game do it by clicking
on the link so they can be tracked
however we all know that this is not the
case some of the users who watch the
video and still download the game do it
without clicking on the link and so it's
really hard to understand what is the
value and what is the size of this non
tract majority and so the classical ways
that developers use nowadays to do that
is to look at the performance of the
video look at how many people click on
the link and download the game and try
to estimate this K factor of users who
watch the video didn't click but still
download and how to do that
you would usually look at your install
numbers over time and try to estimate
how many of these users that you see in
these bikes are coming through the video
itself well that's a really hard thing
to do and it's even harder whenever
there is noise in the installs so try to
imagine that you just launched your game
there would be spike in installs anyway
even without videos or try to think that
you're running an paid campaign at the
same time how do you know how much of
these users this non truck majority is
coming from paid organic or the video
itself but let me spend a minute to talk
about this non trade minority who are
these users so these are people who are
watching the video
and decided not to click on the link but
still download the game or maybe they
didn't see the click the link
it could be users who watch the video
download the game but wait for Wi-Fi not
to use their whole data plan while
installing or it could be also users
watching the video NPC and then just
grab in the phone next to them to
download the game does this sound
familiar great so we thought that we as
Google we are in a unique position to
try to help you to understand the value
and the size of this non-drug majority
and so we developed a methodology that
I'm really excited to share with you
today so what we did we combined the
knowledge that we have from YouTube
meaning users watching videos and from
play I mean in the same users than going
on the store and hopefully install in
the game and so with this methodology we
have been able to see out of the cohorts
of users who have been exposed to
watched a YouTube gaming video featuring
a particular game how many of these same
users after viewership went into the
Play Store and downloaded the game and
then we want to go one step further and
try to understand what is the value of
these users so we also checked how many
of them turned into buyer and if they do
how much they spend over time after
viewing the video and so then we use
this methodology to analyze a pool of
more than 120 videos making up a total
of 50 million views and in order not to
be biased with the results that we are
going to share with you today we took
examples from developers of all sizes
from genre and with games at different
lifecycle stages and then we mix it up
also on the influencer side so we took
examples from micro as well as more
established influencers and also from
gaming as well as non gaming influencers
and so I'm really excited now to share
with you some of the insights that we
have so let's jump into measuring
influencer and the key insights that we
have so we divided the insights into two
main buckets instance about the gamers
and I will go through them and
insights about the influencers and Toby
will come back to talk to you about that
so the gamers I'm sure that the question
that everyone is asking themselves right
now is we talked about this non non
right majority how big it is while I'm
very glad to tell you today that using
our methodology we saw that there are 4x
more installs beyond the tracking link
that means that next time that you do an
influencer marketing campaign for every
person that you see that watches the
video clicks on the link and download
the game you can expect on average to
have four more people who do the same
without clicking and by the way 4x is
just an average this multiplier can be
as high as 10x depending on the type of
content and the type of game that the
creator is featuring and so the follow
up question that we had after that after
understanding how big is this non-drug
majority is how does the distribution of
the install look like over time do they
come all at the same time do they come
after a few hours after few days and so
on and so what we saw is that on average
50% of the install come within the first
hour after users viewed the video on
YouTube but then you may also think ok
but what about if I want to know and
good attribution we know to capture all
the installs not just 50% then we saw
that after four days the installs start
to be flat so users after the moment
when they watch the video it take about
four days to decide whether or not to
install the game so if you're not sure
of the attribution window to use for
your next influencer marketing campaign
then four days is a good one second
insight is about ripple effect across
your portfolio so similar games will get
in installs as well even if they are not
shown or featured in your game in your
video so what we saw is that for an
influencer marketing campaign showing a
particular game in your portfolio let's
call it
game a then you can also get installs in
game B in your portfolio even if he was
not shown in the video itself so for
every ten people who watch the video and
download the game a there is also one
person on average which would go one
step further and download also game B
from your portfolio and again one out of
ten is just an average this multiplier
can be as high as three people out of
ten people depending on the type of
influencer and also depending if the
users who install the first game in your
portfolio love it so much that want to
try another one
so last insights is about targeting
targeting matters focus on your key
audience
well this insight may sound a little bit
obvious however what is interesting to
see is that this is not always true and
it really depends on the metric that you
want to drive so if you want to drive
installs that is definitely the case so
the Creator which had the audience with
a demographic that matches as much as
possible the demographic of the game
itself those videos are the ones who
have the highest install per view rates
however if you want to drive trend this
is not always the case because what we
saw from the data is that on average
users between 24 and 49 years old are 3x
more likely to spend than younger users
and by the way whenever they've spent
they have on average a 30% higher
average revenue per paying user so next
time you do a campaign think about what
you want to drive if you want to drive
installs then definitely focus on your
key audience if you want to DRI spend
focus on the users between 24 and 49
because they are more likely to buy and
when they buy they spend more so let me
now pass it over to Toby to talk about
the insights on the influencers thank
you
Thank You Francisco and he's actually
not the best piece I play on our team
that's something else okay so I will now
talk a bit about the insights we have
gathered when it comes to the
influencers because Francesco and I did
not only look at influencer videos we
also talked to many developers to
understand a bit better how they are
working with influencers and one thing
we have been hearing pretty often is
that once a developer is finding an
influencer to work with the developer
likes to work with them again and again
well this is something you can do but we
also saw an effect you might want to be
aware of and this is something what we
call download fatigue because if you
work with the same creator again within
the time period of a year the second
video will have on average 2x less
installs compared to the first video so
you can draw the conclusion that gamers
who will see the first video of a
specific creator we either convert or
not and you still might want to work
again with the same creator because
maybe you want to work with them to
build your community to re-engage users
or there was just a good deal but this
is something to be aware of secondly
when we were talking to developers we
were discussing so what is the
performance of these influencer
marketing campaign we looked at all the
data we have gathered and one major
thing we found out is that many people
out there try to measure influencer
campaigns just as the same way as they
measure app install campaigns I would be
a little bit cautious here because one
happens to campaigns are if you run them
on the classic performance marketing
Network a bit different if you only look
at the setup if you work with an
influencer you need to find the right
influencer you need to communicate with
them need to agree on a payment model
and if you are run ads with Google USC
or any other network you basically have
a creative bidding and a budget and
that's it and furthermore if you look at
influencer marketing campaigns based on
traditional performance marketing
api's they might not perform as strong
as the average UAC
Facebook or whatever campaign but so
that is that is important to notice but
there's one more thing to be aware of so
one there's more with influences than
just performance and I will tell more
about this very soon and then thirdly we
also found a segment which was highly
profitable and very strong when it comes
to infant marketing and those were
rather small influencers what we call
micro influencers so when we were
looking at smaller influencers with 10
to 100,000 subscribers well these
creators were able to drive CT eyes
which were on average 3x lower than
established influencers and also the
conversion rate which which means the
view to download was very strong as well
well I'm now not saying go away from the
big names because they have some obvious
advantages such as a higher virality and
so on and so forth but if you are still
not sure about influencer marketing you
know remember when Francesco asked all
of you at the very beginning maybe
working with smaller influencers could
be a nice and less risky way a good
entry point to use this tool for
acquiring users so much for working with
micro influencers this is a summary now
of all the research we have been doing
over the past month and feel free to
share all these lessons learned across
your company with product Falls with
marketing folks with game analytical
folks because I think it's it's
important that every function of your
company is aware of these effects and
then you can make the best out of it for
your specific case so we talked about
the installs the no direct majority we
talked about ripple effects that
targeting is important there's also a
download fatigue influencer campaigns
need to be measured a bit differently
probably than traditional performance
marketing campaigns and there's a strong
potential when it comes to micro
influencers so what's next what's now
last but not least I would like to work
with
you on building now an influencer
strategy because for you the big
question is now I've listened to all
this research what shall I do now when
I'm at my desk tomorrow morning or on
Monday morning so Francesca I've thought
about this and we were thinking okay so
maybe if you attend play time you go
back to your office and you talk to your
marketing person or maybe you're a
marketing person yourself and not to use
any stereotypes here but the average
performance marketing person might look
a bit like this so let's say you go back
to the office and talk to him or her
what will you say well our idea would be
tell them about the golden rules for
influencer marketing because what we did
is we took all these lesson learned and
we now have a recommendation for each of
these effects and this is one thing you
can take home with or take to the office
I'm not sure what you want to do at home
but you can take these lessons learned
with you and apply them in your daily
business so one consider the multipliers
to forex the non tracked majority when
you evaluate your influencer marketing
campaigns to be aware of the ripple
effects and be also aware that users
might download a similar game which is
not from you but may be from a
competitor so this is something to be
aware of and again if you're not too
sure about influencer marketing maybe
wait until you have a similar game in
your portfolio so you can finally
benefit a bit from that ripple effect
then thirdly stick to the targeting of
your key audience and stick to the
targeting of users between twenty four
and forty nine years when it comes to
download fatigue just be aware that the
first video is the video which is
generating all these installs and if you
engage again with a developer sorry with
a with a creator it will be about
re-engagement and when it comes to
influence our campaigns well our
thinking is one try to be very
performance-based try to have CPI or
even revenue share deals with
influencers try to go away from those
CPM deals obviously this is always a
thing to do negotiate for and with and
there differ
strategies but this is at least one
thing you can do and then also you can
hatch against the risk that maybe some
users who come to your game after
watching a video of an influencer that
these users do not convert and pay well
if you have ads in your game you can
hatch against this risk because every
install can mean a person who's watching
and at a rewarded video and then last
but not least for the micro influencers
we think that there's a real opportunity
here do not only focus on the big names
and that's why we thought let's give you
also some best practices for working
with micro influencers and again there
are many more best practices but this is
just something to start with
so one the one thing is how do you find
those those people who could be
interested in your game well one very
simple ideas just go on YouTube and
check out who is streaming your game
already
maybe they know other influencers maybe
they have subscribed to some channels
try to dig into this topic try to really
find those people who would be genuinely
interested in your game because if these
guys grow you know your game will grow
with them secondly it's a good
bargaining position for you if somebody
is not as established so you can try to
make good deals you should always do
fail deals because there's always comma
involved in the gaming industry but
there is definitely a good bargaining
power on your side and then third if
this is working for you think of scaling
up think of working with several micro
influencers at the same time and if you
think this holds out all good but I do
not have so much time for this maybe
consider working with an agency or a
third party which really knows this
stuff and you can now use all the
lessons learn from today to evaluate and
brief these third parties so you can be
sure that they deliver the results
you're looking for so so much for the
performance market here in yourself or
in your company but we thought there is
a bit more to influences than just
performance so when you go back to your
company maybe do not only talk to the
marketing person maybe also talk to the
guy or girl who
looking into social media and PR and
again not to use any stereotypes here
but that person might look a bit like
this so the important thing is that
community building can help you to drive
performance in the long term and that's
why you should empower this person as
much as the market here in your team and
why because communities can help you to
be successful in the long term and we
try to come up with a formula because we
here at Google to explain why that is so
one there's the rising quality of new
releases out there there are increasing
marketing costs and there are more and
more multiplayer games getting released
and that means these users are occupied
by other games already so it's just
getting more competitive right and that
means there's a need for creating a
community because only if you create a
community you will be able to survive
with the game for more than three four
or five years and creating communities
well this is all what influencers are
about so do not only think of the
performance marketing aspect to also
think of the long-term benefits of
working with influencers and opinion
leaders and I would like to show you now
one example of the developer who has
worked with an influencer to build a
community even ahead of the release of
the game space ape games invited team
secret to their office to play the new
game Rumble League which has not even
been released yet so let's see how it
looks like if there's a tournament
between the developer and an eSports
team
[Music]
[Applause]
very cool very cool so I think this is a
great example of building a community
even if your game has not been released
yet the influencers are playing directly
against the developers they create bonds
they will reach out again and again and
this is a very very strong way to be
successful in the long term and that
also leads me to my conclusion the idea
is to not only think of performance but
also to think of performance but just
add this thinking that videos and
influencers are more and ideally get the
performance marketing person and the
social media person together or maybe
have a job description which is
combining both jobs if you're a smaller
company you have this already so this is
the idea of driving success with
influencers I would like to conclude now
this presentation by coming back to Yann
you remember him that was the influencer
Francesco introduced to you at the very
beginning he has a channel called oj
gaming with 1 million subscribers so he
definitely knows something about
building communities but now I wonder
what he actually thinks of today's
presentation let's hear it from himself
excellent presentation thank you for
that I hope everyone enjoyed the inside
and influencers on YouTube me and
everyone else are super excited to be
working with you and now playtime
thank you very much and if you were not
convinced that building communities and
engaging users makes sense well now this
was the reason why it is important this
person just engaged all of you our top
partners in amia within 12 seconds if
you have any more ideas requests or
questions please ask them now or also
for more extensive questions and ideas
please leave your feedback under geo /
play / influencer value and now
francesca and myself are happy to take a
few questions right now if you have any
questions please raise your hand and
you'll get a mic okay just a quick
question for one of the loud parts you
brought up regarding using influences to
use to build communities pre or prior to
start like what was the outcome except
for the video I think you need to ask
space safe games together to get the
result of that but what I would
personally say is it is a long-term
approach right because the outcome is
you have influencers who then know the
game you can be in touch with again and
you can also be in touch with the people
they know this is just one eSports team
so I think this is just you know a very
very small shot of a longer term
strategy and approach which will just
help to have an organic impact once the
game is getting released so let's say
it's a bit like if you're planning a big
party and you're already making friends
a few months before so this way the
people will come once you have the party
which will be the launch of the game
that's what I assume
one more working mic yeah yeah thank you
thank you for the awesome position I
think most of us were waiting for this
kind of attack for quite some time
I'd like to ask you please if you could
elaborate more of the execution itself
so let's say I found my pool of
influencers and I want to execute the
campaign
what specifically would I need to do to
make use of this view through
attribution with the windows for the
place or it may be that if there are
maybe some plans or strategies how to
make it more accurate also for other
platforms as of course the in fluid
traffic would have spillover effects on
any platform where the game is thank you
so sorry just the question is how to use
these these insights or what exactly so
I just had active reactivated tonight
please okay okay so so if you just the
inside or we can use okay
so today was all about the insights
because we are coming from a long
journey trying to look at this topic and
helping developers so this is basically
an experiment and a pilot if you know
think I want to use this I want to have
this for my business
jido / play / influence our value please
give us this feedback because only if we
have more ideas and requests that you
want to use you know this this
technology or this attribution as part
of your business only then we can drive
forward with this project yes thank you
very much yes I think there was a
question what the front as well
sorry yeah hi
BOSU thank you very much for the you
guys for the presentation is your
methodology and results also applicable
to premium games yeah absolutely I mean
we just at the look at a court of users
watching a game and then what do they do
on the Play Store so that applies
absolutely to any game free or paid or
anything
yeah thanks is super useful presentation
quick question I think one of the
challenge as well is very often to refer
link on YouTube is not very visible it's
a bit below and all that are there any
plans to make that referral link or have
something a bit more powerful than that
so we are looking into this but you also
know when we are looking at to things
like Google it can sometimes take a
while but we are very very aware that
right now this solution it looks like
like a hack right it looks like very
very on the fly and this is still
something what we use in in the industry
and which is more or less the standard
except that we now try to look a bit
beyond this so hopefully at some point
that's what I think personally but we
are we're looking at the space and again
feel free to add this feedback yes so
we're trying to you know we're trying to
begin a movement here and we won't be
happy if you're a part of it yes yes how
many well there's no there's no
threshold so we get as many as possible
Thanks
so one more question here we have time
for one more question one more question
okay okay if there are no more questions
left then I think we are quite early or
even on time that's the thing about
being in Germany so I'm now happy to
send you off to to lunch but before we
do that please make sure to check out
all the games we have in the playground
so we have VR games air games AI games
there's even a Google Play quiz so you
can test your Google Play knowledge and
you even can try your skills in a
scooter race so please go back through
through the outdoor area and be back for
the sessions at 2:00 p.m. because then
we will listen about monetization and
that is something you do not want to
miss as a game developer thank you